on the hill tonight for the giants is
kevin gausman the ace of the staff
the model of consistency in his four
starts this year he has gone six plus
innings every time out there
and take a look at just 23 strikeouts at
25 and two thirds
chisholm stands in swing and that's how
this game gets started
here comes magnuris sierra left-handed
hitter and a speedster
the 1-1 pitch and a little change-up is
flipped into shallow left out goes dubon
from short and
he's got it out number two two down
nobody on and here comes
jesus aguilar and the pinch swung out of
misty struck him out
with the splitter and the inning is over
two strikeouts for gaussman three up and
three down
bottom of the first jose devers is over
at second base tonight making his major
league
debut so uh terrific young prospects for
the marlins inside their top ten
on the hill tonight for the marlins will
be the right-hander pablo lopez
three-quarter release with a good
fastball it's got a great change up
curveball slider combo
tommy listella leads things off la
stella grounds one maybe off the glove
of lopez and ever is able to make the
play so i i'm guessing that's kind of
what you want right if you're endeavors
let me
get into the action right off the bat
here yeah you're just trying to get the
heart rate to go down a little bit no
matter what's going on you know he's
going to be excited for the game tonight
the first at-bat's going to be exciting
i probably got a lot going on here is
yasremski 2-2 on the way
cut on and miss 95 miles an hour from
pablo lopez again all nine on the
changeup last time out against the
giants that one an elevated fastball
so two down here is wilmer flores ground
ball left side
up with it birdie across the first and
pablo lopez with a one two three person
here's guzman to garrett cooper tall
right-handed hitter with power
now he's swinging it's a high drive in a
deep center field going back to slater
he's at the warning track right in front
of the wall he leaps
he makes the catch he stole a home run
from garrett cooper
and snater timed his leap perfectly
would it have gone out
yeah i don't know but it was close
austin slater the center fielder
now the stretch here it comes and slater
takes called strike three caught him
looking at a fastball
so pablo with the second strike i won in
the first one here
in the second jose devers will lead
things off making his major
league debut tonight and this is his
first major league plate appearance
got him so his first big league at bat
is a strikeout four strikeouts now
for gaussman through the first seven
hitters of the game here's a swing and a
miss another change up strike three
two more strikeouts for kevin gausman in
the top of the third
pablo lopez and pablo kind of picking up
gabby where he left off against these
giants last weekend in miami
yeah he's been he's been outstanding
today get the play by john birdie on the
backhand
very nicely done and an error in the
second but makes a
stellar defensive play here in the third
yeah right the air came on the easy play
this was not easy at all
so now gaussman as a hitter against
lopez
with one out and nobody on there's a
swing and a miss at a change up down and
away
gosman down on strikes the third punch
shot for pablo a swing and a miss a
fastball up
a strikeout on a fastball for pablo
lopez he's got four k's
jazz chisholm for the marlins against
kevin gausman here hitting number four
nothing nothing he's an o2 he's called
strike three a fastball
chisholm didn't like it and that was
really really generous
that's that wide strike zone from mike
malinsky
he rings up jazz chisholm one away
already
six kevin gausman strikeouts in this
game aguilar hits a
one-hop liner diving la stella knocks it
down picks it up throws off balance to
first
he got him what a play by tommy lestella
stella laying out knocked it down had to
get to his feet
pick the ball up spin around and throw
to first from the shallow outfield grass
and he did it great defense there
neither team has had a hit in this game
only one base runner into the bottom of
the fourth
mike ustremski for the giants pablo
lopez
with another strikeout that's his fifth
with one out here in the fourth the
swing in the miss he struck by a change
up
so pablo another one two three inning he
has fanned
six grossman hasn't allowed a hit pablo
lopez hasn't allowed one
here's dickerson who hit a little
comebacker to guzman
and they have their first hit of the
night finally a base hit
for corey dickerson with one out here in
the fifth here you have first and second
one out they've got to find a way to
cash in
sets up the biggest at bat in the career
of jose devers
strikes out swinging on a high fastball
he went upstairs at 96
miles an hour big second out seventh
strikeout for kevin gausman
so two down and sandy leone his one-two
pitch leone bounces it to second la
stella has
this one throws to first for out number
three
so the error does not cost gaussman so
alex dickerson stands in against
pablo lopez nothing nothing bottom five
hit well to left center field dickerson
on the move he's not gonna get it
the first hit for the giants is a double
by alex dickerson
with nobody out in the fifth the giants
have been at second and third
trying to strike first in this game the
most trouble that pablo lopez has been
in tonight austin slater to the plate
the marlins are going to play the
infield back swinging the ground ball to
third breaking for the play dickerson
the high hop glove by birdie he's going
to throw the first in time
giants have taken a one-nothing lead
pablo lopez due to lead off
against kevin gossman the way gosman's
going tonight that one run might be all
he needs
change up struck him out swinging
strikeout number eight
for guardsman the right-hander throws he
struck him out swinging with the
splitter
and the inning is over nine strikeouts
in six innings
for guardsmen the giants leader won
nothing but pablo has been really good
he's allowed just one run on one hit in
five innings out to center
and sierra makes a diving play
he can cover some ground what a play to
take a hit away from kevin gausman yeah
he sure can this young man has got some
uh
foot speed some instincts now wilmer
flores the o2 pitch
swinging a bouncer back up the middle
right there though the second baseman
behind the back at second devers has it
tosses to chisholm covering they get the
force out of the stella and pablo makes
it through the six
for kevin gausman who should have plenty
in the tank just rolled through this
miami marlins lineup nine strikeouts two
down
for john bertie that's a high drive deep
left center field
john bernie with a home run birdie
birdie birdie
he has homered against kevin gossman to
tie this game in one
that's the spark the marlins have been
desperately looking for
gaussman is still in this game 89
pitches
through seven two hit innings here's a
splitter
swung out and missed he struck him out
strikeout number 11
that equals the career record for
kevin gausman in the big league game
bell will scurry to the bag
and that'll end the inning eight
sensational innings
from kevin gausman off man on tonight
things may get a little interesting give
aguilar a chance to hit one in the gap
and aguilar is a really good fastball
hitter and he smokes this one to left
center field that is going to
go wow a frozen rope to left center and
aguilar with a two run shot marlins take
the lead tonight
and now a single by cooper the first
three have reached against this rookie
santos
juan de peralta takes over against corey
dickerson
and now dickerson toward triples alley
that is going to get down
cooper on his way to third he is being
waved around
here comes the throw it's headed toward
third that's why they call it triples
alley
it's now 4-1 marlins it's a 5-1 marlins
lead bullpens done a real nice job for
the marlins so far
one away here is yaz the pitch yes hits
one a mile to right
deep on its way to the water goodbye
that one is wet five to two miami
and there are two outs tonight dickenson
the hitter and this one is
in the air to left field it's a marlins
win